emotional response of course in all
respects not only in terms of the
opportunity of playing someone so iconic
so wonderful so beloved but also just
the team of people who've brought this
movie to the big screen are all at the
top of their game Charles Martin Julian
Bay Dexter Fletcher Matthew Warren
George Richmond
it's an incredible team of filmmakers
and I am very proud to be alongside a
total joy and it never felt like hard
work it just felt like an extraordinary
privilege I really feel like I'm
addressed these issues several times I
really do and I think tonight I want to
celebrate what the movie is which is a
joyous celebration of someone's life
without getting lost in that stuff
because whilst they recognize these
issues are important I really do feel of
addressing I absolutely love it
not only is you everything everyone
knows him to be which is a musical
genius a great philanthropist he is the
most fun naughty irreverent kind
brilliant man I cannot stress enough how
fantastic he is
so I haven't got a job lined up yes I'm
available okay the man of the hour we
will leave him to celebrating with the
rest of the car